there's been a lot of confusion lately
about the nfl's partial ban on
participation in the scouting combine
certain types of players based upon
off-field history will not be allowed to
fully participate now it started as a
complete ban it's been softened to
permit
showing up for physicals and also
limited participation in interviews but
there is a standard in place and it's
caused some confusion because there's a
player out there named carl granderson
wyoming defensive end he is facing
charges of felony third degree
sexual assault and misdemeanor sexual
battery
the difference is he hasn't been
convicted that is the key
that will put a player on the wrong side
of the nfl scouting combine ban you have
to have a conviction specifically if
there has been a felony or misdemeanor
conviction involving violence or use of
a weapon domestic violence sexual
offense and or sexual assault any of
those things felony or misdemeanor and
you're subject to the partial scouting
kanban ban and here's why that makes no
sense
if you've had something happen recently
that you did
you actually did it you're responsible
you're guilty but it happened so
recently that they haven't been able to
turn it into a conviction you're still
invited to the scouting combine
consider how that compares with the
nfl's personal conduct policy which will
take action against the player even if
there isn't a conviction they'll do
their own investigation and come to
their own conclusion so this is just
another reason why that whole rule needs
to go away as i said recently it doesn't
hurt the players it hurts the teams the
players are still going to be evaluated
the players are still going to be
drafted this weird pr idea that not
letting them come to indianapolis that
that isn't anything that helps the nfl
it just makes it harder to properly
evaluate the players and i don't know
that there was anyone in the media or
anyone among the fans saying these guys
who got in trouble at some point in
their past they need to be prevented
from coming to the scouting combine
players don't view it as an honor to be
at the scouting combine it's all part of
the evaluation process the sooner the
nfl realizes that this isn't hurting the
players that it is hurting the teams
that the rules are inconsistent that
it's impossible to really work this out
the way they're trying to work it out
maybe they'll just get rid of this
scouting combine ban once and for all
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports